aber meine mutter mal dazu im programm
danach wurde ich in die zur geschichte
der usa skates und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute ist mit aber
dass die herren und damen ist mega wird
weil ihr seht max jetzt gerade aber ich
lebe nicht und ja okay ich dachte er
wäre tot erklärt noch alles klar
heute gibt es wieder spannende perverse
peinliche professionelle zuschauer
geschichten wir legen direkt los leute
formular um eure geschichten einzusenden
ist wie immer im ersten wagen wir als
erste geschichte vor zirka zwei wochen
wo ich mit dem bus von der schule nach
hause ich fahre sonst immer bahn aber
die hatte verspätung als sie mich
hinsetze viel meine tasche auf dem boden
welche dummerweise offen war und alle
kondome die meine freundin mir für mich
und meinen freund geschenkt hat zulage
auf dem boden verteilt leute stellt euch
vor ihr sitzt im bus sitzt euch
gegenüber so ein 14-jähriges mädchen ja
wahrscheinlich german let's play fan t
shirt an mega unschuldig fest ihre
tasche
auf einmal kommt da so einen bach an
kondomen raus wir denke ich einfach so
hälfte jahrzehnten tag muss sein oder
wie siehst du es kann auch der nächste
geschichte kommt von einem mädchen hallo
es kam mir ist etwas richtig peinlich
ist passiert ich bin ein bus gestiegen
und habe mich dort auf dem platz der
eigentlich für schwangere und ältere
menschen geeignet war gesetzt ein
älterer mann sprach mich dann an ob ich
den platz freimachen würde da ist der
letzte platz im bus war sagte ich ich
bin schwanger was und dann passiert
immer das unglaubliche meine lehrerin
die nur ein paar plätze weiter hinten
saß stand auf und ging zu mir und meinte
wir müssen unbedingt ein elterngespräch
führen da ich erst 16 bin ich konnte sie
nicht davon überzeugen dass ich nicht
schwanger bin
das gespräch war der horror mit
schulleiter und pipapo hier wird sagen
icon bullshit ist eine sehr lebhafte
fantasie sich so etwas auch zu dingen
aber es ist irgendwie auch zu
unwahrscheinlich als das ist echt ist
wir müssen eltern gespräch führen
das ist glaube ich denke ich kann es aus
leute willkommen dahinter bemerken dass
alles teilte die nächste geschichte
kommt auch direkt aus dem leben das ist
einfach glaubhaft versteht ihr wenn es
um die geschichte hört das ist einfach
glaubhaft da denke ich okay das hätte
mir genauso passieren können und zwar
als ich sechs war bin ich mit einem
regenschirm von der treppe gesprungen
und habe mir mein bein verstaucht als
wir dann im krankenhaus war hat meine
mom erzählt dass ich regenschirm mit
falschem verwechselt habe ps das war
peinlich genau wo wir heute gar nicht
wissen wie oft ich das probiert habe ich
hab das echte hoffnung macht dass sie
irgendwo gesprochen wir mit einem
regenschirm man gedacht haben das wird
habe ich eigentlich auch
[Musik]
aber aber seine das natürlich denkt
stellt sky greifen so ein bisschen
fliegt im flugzeug hoch springt dann
raus und max hasst regenschirm mit
falschen verwechselt hat lassmann
leiterin die situation die hätte man
leute wir wollen zwar realistische
geschichten aber okay ich lese aber vor
ich war krank und bin zu meinem hobby
touren gegangen so ja kein langes
vorspiel der hammer kommt direkt dann
habe ich mich auf dem weg eine katze wo
man hier das war nach rausgegangen habe
eine große klassen und bin wieder
losgegangen
beim tourengehen jetzt kommt aber ich
beim springen meine trainerin ich
angeklagt was ihr lover
das ist doch nicht echt die da steht das
sind die die zuschauer von wirklich
youtube hatte sich auch noch mal von 14
also aber ich frage mich wirklich ob die
leute da zu hause sitzen und dann so was
tippen und ich denke hh der escape
bestimmt das ist echt möchte von allen
guten geistern verlassen vor allem was
hast du bitte für eine verdauen
du läufst hingis nach hause
katzenmenschen okay die nächste sache
ist tatsächlich was was man selbst auch
sehr gut kennt und zwar ich jonas
männlich 16 war krank und trotzdem in
der schule vorbesitzern übels lustiger
typ der die ganze zeit 08 wir verstehen
uns echt gut und er dreht sich manchmal
um um ihr was zu erzählen und neulich
hat er sich umgedreht und ich musste
niesen und die ganze kam aus meiner nase
und er hat alles gesehen ist ihr schon
mal passiert in der schule gibst du es
ist ja schon mal passiere ich weiß dass
noch als wäre es heute das warm an aller
erster schultag und ich wollte nicht
dass ich wollte halt nicht so denn es
ist ja oft so wenn du dann ersten
schultag in der grundschule rücken hab
ich irgendwie geweint und wollte
irgendwie mal mama bleiben wir das so
denn beim wein ist mir das passiert und
ich habe drei meter auf eine affäre aus
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
dann kommt er kommt die lehrerin und
den eltern gespräch nicht und du bist
dann auch schwanger kein tag in der
schule hat ja auch noch schulleiter kag
dann auch sich und seine touren lehrerin
an alles nur weil du musst du aus diesem
grund leute immer taschentücher dabei
haben wollt ihr schulze der schüler der
die ganze schule anpackt wollt ihr nicht
also okay die nächste geschichte hört
einfach ganz genau zu was jetzt vor dem
ok körper zu die geschichte fängt an
alles klein geschrieben ich habe mich
versucht aber meine mutter war da und
hat es mitbekommen danach wo die ich in
die suche geschickt
ich habe mich versucht aber meine mutter
war da danach wurde ich in die zu
kathrin zettel cht r der sich versorgt
was daran verboten
jeder kann es doch mal versuchen das ist
geschrieben ist versichern24 mitbewohner
stehe jetzt schon wieder in der küche
das heißt sie haben das alle mit grüßen
euch jetzt gerade ok nächste geschichte
in der zweiten klasse war ich mal
schlecht gelaunt und daraufhin bin ich
einfach so oft wird ihr gegangen um zu
wissen
es geht weiter als ich reinkam bekam ich
ärger und ich habe es nicht gesehen
also haben wir uns gestritten als ob das
nicht schon reicht achtung habe ich hier
extra mit in die fresse gekotzt
der zweiten klasse halten was ist das
für ein bewundernswerter menschen kann
einfach auch er kann einfach auf
kommando trotzen
das ist einfach so matt und er geht
einfach passen weil im herbst
und hier kommt zurück und wir kurz tier
mit mir die fresse
aber man muss ihm zugutehalten hat nicht
alle register gezogen hat ja auch ins
gesicht kann und wird den schulleiter
okay leute die nächste geschichte hat
auch schon wieder richtig potenzial ein
guter freund von mir nennen wir ihn mal
lewis ist schrägstrich war in einer
meiner besten freundin verliebt nennen
wir sie lauter dann hat sich louis
ausgedacht dass er krebs hat um locker
zu bekommen menschlich gesehen klar
warum auch nicht nächste geschichte wir
hatten mal einen lehrer der in der pause
immer seine klasse aufs klo gelassen hat
aber die anderen klassen nicht also
eines tages als ich gefragt ob darf ich
auf toilette meinte er so nein aber er
hat ein mädchen aus der anderen klasse
rein gelassen
ich war so mega sauer da habe ich gesagt
wenn sie mich nicht reinlassen kaka auf
ihren kopf was habt ihr ja es ist die
geschichte
ich bin vor zwei wochen mit einer
freundin spazieren gegangen alles normal
bis sie stolpere und auf sie gefallen
bin ich wurde ganze rot und schämte mich
denn unsere lippen sind
aneinandergeraten
bitte meinen namen nicht sagen danke er
ist mit einer freundin spazieren
gegangen ist auf sie gefallen erstmal
man fällt erstmal nicht auf leute ist
auf sie gefallen
sie fällt um er wird ganz so roth damals
brachen heute ihre lippen sind hört euch
jetzt ja auch gesagt dass ich schwanger
ist aber klar
erzählen wir die geschichte und er
schreibt einfach sie schreibt einfach
das ist alles ist einfach einsatz ohne
satzzeichen
ich war im technikunterricht und habe in
die hand gelegt
leute ohne wird 20 hierfür einsendungen
haben die einsendung heißt einfach ich
habe fußball gespielt ohne apa red warum
macht das war es von diesem video ich
glaube ich war zunächst mal für die
nächste folge von diesem format und
anführungszeichen mal vor die einsendung
aussuchen weil er echt richtig viel
würde und seltsame scheiße dabei ist
dass dabei auch noch um zeit und chips